PROFESSOR: So besides
our physical expectation
that a virus such as
SARS-CoV-2, coronavirus,
could be transmitted through
respiratory droplets,
especially aerosol droplets
through the airborne route
of transmission, there
is substantial evidence--
both epidemiological evidence
and some physical evidence--
to support this hypothesis.
So first, let's
go through some of
the epidemiological evidence.
This is a very small fraction
of what is available to date.
So one of the first
incidents that
gave a sense there might
be airborne transmission
was a religious event that took
place at the Tiantong Temple
in Ningbo China, where
there were hundreds
of people in attendance.
But in particular,
there were two buses
that brought worshippers
in one-hour bus rides
to this location.
And on one of the
buses was what was
known to be the first
infected person with COVID-19,
entering this region
after having had contact
with others from Wuhan
China, the initial source
of the outbreak.
And on the bus where
the infected person was,
23 out of 68 passengers became
infected during that ride.
And despite the fact
that there was also
contact in the larger
temple building
with many other people, very
few there were infected.
And on the second bus, where
they kept the same seating,
there were no infections.
So that gave a sense that
on public transportation,
there could be substantial
superspreading going on.
So shortly afterwards, there
were a number of incidents,
including a case in a
restaurant in Guangzhou, China,
where an infected person
was sitting at a table
having dinner with
a party there.
And there was a
documented transmission
to a far corner of
the room with a person
who had not been within a
short distance such as six
feet of the infected
person, had not touched
anything that could have
led to contact transmission.
And it was concluded that
it could only be explained
by airborne transmission.
Then there was a well-known
case involving a cruise ship--
one of several such cases--
of the Diamond Princess
cruise ship, where
a few infections were detected.
And on February
3, 2020, the ship
was quarantined in the
harbor of Yokohama, Japan.
And during that quarantine,
out of 3,011 passengers
and crew on the ship, there were
a total, at the end of 12 days,
of 354 infected
persons, starting
from an initial estimate of--
well, several known cases.
And by our own analysis,
we will be estimating
there were perhaps around
20 initial cases, so
a dramatic increase in the
number of infected persons
in 12 days, despite the fact
that the passengers were mostly
confined to their cabins with
very little movement between.
And also, later analysis
showed that there
was very little statistical
correlation between contact
with an infected person
even being in the same room
and getting a transmission.
In other words,
transmission was happening
between people in
different rooms,
even on different
floors, presumably
through the air handling system.
And among many other
events that followed,
another famous case was
one of the initial sources
of spreading in South Korea was
the Shincheonji Church, which
held services over the
period of February 16 to 25.
And a significant fraction
of thousands of churchgoers
were infected, that led to
the initial outbreak in Korea,
again, coming from contact of a
large number of people sharing
an indoor space, where
it's not possible for each
of those people to have
been touching each other
or within 3 or 6 feet.
But rather, the only
plausible explanation
is transmission through the air.
Another such
example in Korea had
to do with a call
center, where it
was hundreds of people working
in a building with many floors.
And there was an infected
person in one large room of one
of the floors.
And a significant
fraction of the co-workers
were infected in that call
center and yet a relatively
small number in other
parts of the same floor
or on other floors,
again pointing
to airborne transmission
after subsequent analysis.
And then one of the first cases
in the United States famously
occurred in the
Skagit Valley Chorale,
which was holding a
choir practice in Mount
Vernon, Washington, USA.
We will be analyzing
this case in more detail.
But it very dramatically
showed the evidence
for airborne transmission,
because in a 2 and 1/2 hour
choir practice, one infected
person managed to infect 53 out
of 61 others, two
of whom later died,
when it could be
documented that there
was no direct contact,
short-range contact,
or touching between
all of those people.
But rather, they simply
shared the same indoor space.
Also there was a
hint that respiration
and the type of
respiration was important,
in that these
people were singing.
And that led to a
dramatic increase
in the rate of
transmission compared
to other airborne events.
There are many other examples
one could go through.
There have also been,
recently, some meta analyses
of large numbers of
cases, which further
point towards indoor airborne
transmission of COVID-19.
One recent such study
looked at 7,300 cases
of initial spreading
of COVID-19 out
of the epicenter of the outbreak
in Hubei Province, China.
So they looked at 320
cities, to the first known
cases in those cities
outside of Hubei Province.
And they identified
all the clusters
of two or more transmissions.
And of those clusters--
there were 72 of them.
And they all occurred indoors.
And out of those, 80% were at
home in people's apartments.
And 34% also included some
public transportation.
And out of all those
clusters of transmission,
only one was documented
to be occurring
outdoors, consistent with a
wide range of other evidence.
Moreover, there has
been a cataloging
of superspreading events such
as the ones I've listed here.
And that list now
numbers well over 1,000.
And out of all the
superspreading events
that have been
documented, all of them
have occurred indoors and
involving large enough numbers
of people that airborne
transmission is
the most plausible explanation.
So besides the overwhelming
epidemiological evidence
for airborne
transmission of COVID-19,
there is also growing
physical evidence.
So first of all, other
diseases that we've
discussed in this course,
such as tuberculosis,
a bacterial disease, measles
and the original SARS-CoV
coronavirus, which
are viral diseases,
have all been
established and believed
to be transmitted through
respiratory aerosols.
SARS-CoV-2 is a very similar
coronavirus to SARS-CoV-1.
And so it's plausible that
its mechanism of transmission
would be the same,
if not similar.
And indeed, there has been
recent work demonstrating
that infectious
aerosol droplets could
be isolated from infected
patients with COVID-19.
And in particular, the
most infectious droplets
observed were in
the aerosol range
with radii less than 2 microns.
So the evidence is
growing and frankly
becoming overwhelming that the
airborne route of transmission
is important, if not
dominant, for COVID-19.
So we will continue
now by analyzing
how to mitigate and
model the transmission
of a respiratory
pathogen indoors.